[Applause]
[Music]
it's time
ranking men by attractiveness we saw the
girl version
now it's time for the boys yeah yeah
[Music]
dear beauty all right let's skip the
intro
what that's me if your name is pewdiepie
please wait no i'm felix shelby come on
goodbye
i think you're gonna watch this video
because you watched the first part and
you said you would hell
yeah true true but notice that your
reactions to our videos get way more
views
oh no they've noticed
well i have a couple more subscribers
guys i keep telling you sub to humiliate
it's amazing don't bruh me
so it's only fair that jubilee media
collaborates with pewdiepie
maybe the audience can suggest something
uh spectrum what does pewdiepie think
no we're not doing that hundred women
are raped by alex oh okay
six bros versus one secret pewdiepie
that's kind of fun
yeah i would love to okay guys let me
know in the comments here
yeah hell yeah yeah that sounds fun
let's do that
[Music]
let's get it i'll take it off yeah here
we go
[Applause]
okay so they bring five guys together
and then they're gonna rank themselves
and then the women come in and say no
you did wrong
all right because the girl the girls met
you you me
are these the same guys yeah there is i
don't recognize some of them
[Music]
they just say bass uh sorry i gotta
copyright this video now
okay all right i think i'm good here
well
start with introductions or something
sure yeah i mean you could do that
jeremy is my name
fun fact i used to live in texas so
i think what i didn't understand in the
last video and it wasn't really clear
some feedback for you you believe since
you're watching
i thought it was purely based on
appearance i guess attractiveness can be
your personality it should have been
obvious
it may be another tip here you believe
you got to treat your audience like
they're what they are
extremely dumb just look at me uh i'm
sam
i'm studying astrophysics and i'm an air
force cadet
i'm roy i'm a recent college graduate
studying political science roy is the
cutest though come on roy
don't sell yourself sure guys first of
all right off the bat
i think i don't know about you guys but
this guy looks like a young vin diesel
it's got a good smile i'll give him a
nap he looks better than bindi so
but man's at least five foot come on not
that it matters
oh that reminds me there was such a
funny thing that i didn't notice in the
last video
anthony dude it looks like he's got high
heels i thought for sure he had high
heels
when i saw this the first time i was
like
how did i not notice that why didn't no
one talk about that no he's just a chair
i feel like guys really respect people
with muscles
a lot more because they know what it
takes not that some girls don't work out
this is not as popular right
so i think i think they're going to put
anthony pretty high it looks like tyler1
come on
oh look at him yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah
see what i tell you
i get a lot of compliments and even
though i don't really take compliments
well
i guess there's been enough evidence to
where i know that people find me
attractive
i feel like what we should do nah
anthony come on
you're you're gloating you went down on
my attractiveness scale just say what we
think we are
okay where are you going you don't get
to say you don't get to say okay
i'll go i'll go three three yeah
i think he would look better with a
different haircut right because he has
that vampire hairline
maybe bust cut or something take the
bush bill i would personally put myself
a four or five yeah i'd say four or five
they're all
they're all decent looking games i would
say you're a three i feel like i'm tall
enough
i'm the shortest guy bro yeah yeah by
quite a lot i wish
i'm fine with that now you look like you
put a lot of work in yourself i thought
he was gonna be number one to be honest
so for me really at least has to be a
three or two i
i don't want to be like rude or blunt
but he kind of looks like a frat boy
so i think he should be like a three can
i put a word in for myself yeah
he looks like a indonesian k-pop or
something i think you're up there
personally i'm content with okay i would
put
one two three and these are the
practically the same four or five yeah
being four four or five i stick with
five
you're a pretty good looking guy i think
you're actually pretty cute too roy
i think that's an attractive person
overall but seeing them and
uh maybe not roy sorry i saw him up
close learning more
i'm joking right you're beautiful
personalities i wasn't gonna argue
that they're least attractive than me
actually
i don't know i don't know why am i doing
this i don't even know
i don't know if cameras can pick it up
but i woke up with blemishes today
i got a crooked nose i broke it a few
years ago man i've always had problems
with my
image especially when well then you
shouldn't be wearing you shouldn't be
wearing short socks like that
man that's you're just failing from the
start
uh okay maybe one two three
four five i don't i keep yeah it's way
harder to rank guys
isn't there a thing that was a thing
right
like girls actually don't care like
unless you're a 10
then you get all the girls but if you're
a nine eight seven six five you're all
in the same group
there was something like that i wanna
want to spread misinformation but that's
what i heard
and for guys it was the opposite effect
personality had much great effects on
women's perception of good luck than men
that's interesting i can see that
uh you need to look older grow a light
beard
hell yeah look older where are my
glasses
build muscle hell yeah be kind
chinese study i can't trust that wear
red
seriously women are most attractive men
wearing red
walk a dog eat garlic
uh let's see yeah he's fit man hell yeah
yeah all right you go up all right let
me scoot one down yeah you go
up yeah scooch down
yeah yeah he got upgraded i'll take the
three
he's like i'm not going lower than three
no
i'll go as low as three yeah you're
content
you're gonna take three three i can't
we haven't got a close-up of his face
yet i would say you two
three four five no offense so he's two
wow
girls like more feminine guys right come
on k-pop
yes i'm really curious what they're
going to rate them
i mean just look at it right now this
guy's dripped out
that's true dude he put some words
i just don't like his clothes i think
that's what ruined it for if he wore
something different
oh yeah that's like plus points you
still gotta have more like you got it
more
appearance yeah i wish i was a little
bit bigger i think it's basically just
them switch
where would you put me where would i
happen to yeah right here is cool
okay yeah yeah man wants to be three
i still think they're wrong and i should
be like here that's cause you're humble
we noticed once he took the jacket off
he moved up a couple spots
come on he come on you got to move up
he's he's got that butt chin
chad chin no one really stands out so
it's hard to put one as
one if you were taller my dude i'm just
kidding
i will put one two
these are same and these three are all
the same really
let's get real here it's impossible
why is it so much harder to rank men
you're all happy
yes i mean it's not terrible
they did roy dirty though are they gonna
move roy
that's the real question and anthony
[Music]
when i saw when the guys were ranking
each other
it's like a first impression type of
thing so basing off
how you look and the conversation that
we heard
for a little time out wait so they heard
their conversation
well that would have been good to know
jubilee
i need to see their booties what
girls look at boys bites no
no why are women into dude buttons
it's fine it's fine i'm really curious
if they're gonna put out anthony because
he
you know to be fair he's got a good
smile nice skin he looks well
not proportionate and can say that i'm
kidding it's got good mouth
yeah i'm curious if the height will play
a role here nothing
nothing nothing okay all right number
one we need to get the tender little
sweetheart that is that is wrong right
now
yeah i knew they would like roy he would
[Music]
all the boys talked over poor roy
honestly i love little baby roy just
kind of shut
the back of the line every single time
and i was like this poor kid
attractiveness for me and it is a
general whole i was like who am i
wanting to go hang out with right now
like if we were done after this they're
going to put roy up
right's going to get upgraded would be
spill a tea kalin
he looks like a bootleg michael b jordan
oh he would go first oh okay well
michael b
jordan oh okay i know what that is yeah
he has a nice haircut his eyes no it's
the wrong haircut i'm sorry there's a
friendly vibe from him it's
just his like eyes and his smile i
thought sam was
the most attractive to me he wasn't
striving to be number one
he was just like place me where i am
yeah
yeah anthony you're going to go down
yeah but i feel like
he also might like cheat on you no
yeah [ __ ] trying to think of something
wow
i don't know i feel like he probably has
a bad temper or something he punches
drywall when he gets angry
it was one two three four five
damn one two three roy hader
um two
three four five just because i'm very
big on height
oh she's big on that going out
and then you go now two
three four five what they're so
different that's crazy
immediately i like the guy in the green
shirt who was shorter made eye contact
and i was like okay cool like i think
that's attractive
is like connection one two three
four five yay okay we're on the same
boat i mean i feel like i like a guy
who's not
so skinny just because i like you know
protection
see i think our hamburgers
how dare you adorable i don't really
like
anybody's outfits today anyway i
understand we're all comfortable
i don't know i think dressing is
important yeah that's fair
can't make me picture them naked that's
weird
pink shirt would go in second and then
everyone would scooch is everyone
let's see yeah let's do it okay right
over there yeah yeah yeah
[Applause]
i would just like to say what a little
angel right what a little
angel get somewhere not inside anthony
is the
i care more about what the girls thought
than the guys
but that's just my own opinion wait so
can you just move up because i
he can't be there yeah can we put him in
third put his switch
little angel
oh this is so cringe i love it oh hell
yeah
bootleg michael b jordan ranks in faith
by the
women toxic masculinity also women
little baby roar
they need to rank them individually
because a lot of opinions are over
shadow yeah
yeah you can see that if your name is
pewdiepie please watch this phillips job
i am 100 okay with this lineup i feel
like i'm okay with this
again very different i guess both men
and women suck at rating each other
outside of
this i would not have looked at any of
the guys
damn past each one of them okay
being in the same room and seeing this
type of personalities that they have
these are some nice guys to be friends
with but we are really
different wow that's so nice of you to
say
[Applause]
she did not just say that get out
i think most of the girls are more
personality based
i don't think it's fair that he's last
but at the same time i don't know
it's good but i mean still you can't
know
off one minute i thought i was gonna be
lower bro don't cry bro don't bro you
don't cry bro you're beautiful you're
both foot don't quite say two
the throughout the second two rounds so
i'm content with my number two
that's what's attractive is a guy who is
attractive but thinks he's not
someone's looking at at my confidence
hey hi this person isn't nice or maybe
this person i wouldn't take him home
with my family like
people make all those assumptions before
they even you know know anything about
you so it's cool to see what people see
outside of your point of view being
judged by other people
based off like a minute is kind of like
giving me like a little bit of anxiety
yeah we do that subconsciously towards
other people
growing up mexican and being latino
attractiveness is set around this like
image of being like
this really like macho muscular you know
bronze
chiseled man with like facial hair and
stuff like that
wait what where do you get what i've
never heard that
i actually typically see or like
associate myself with that
so i i don't i don't think i'm you're
the best mexican i've ever seen in my
life what are you talking about
i do not know what the women are looking
for because apparently i have
some of it and it looks like generic
boyfriend material i think that's why he
got so high doesn't it i hope i figured
out what that is
do you know get out of here get out of
here all right
ubela collaboration potential
epic i'm excited nice these girls are
kind of superficial patronizing and
annoying
well that was the point of the video the
guys did the same thing
remember anyway guys look at the graph
subscribe
you